[Music]
so we're back at the smart castle i'm
ernie o'donnell my boy chris over here
and today we are finally
at like a halfway point we're gonna
start putting some primer on the wall as
you've seen before i was
a mess where we sanded all the walls all
that's been wiped down
everything's been vacuumed clean ready
to go prepped
and we're going to be putting some pva
primer
that's this
lovely stuff this is what we put on the
walls
the ceiling the drywall spackle
any repairs that i may have made reminds
me though what i wanted to say is
in the first episode i told you guys
some of the stuff that we're going to be
doing at the smart castle
and another thing that we want to do is
represent our artists in the vue sq
universe there's a lot of talented
people out there and we always
see your art on facebook twitter
wherever you guys put it
we check it out so at some point in time
the smart castle
will be representing the view of sku
universe artists out there
uh maybe some sort of gallery setup we
do here or a contest or things like that
me and kev are even talking about the
idea of doing a huge mural
on the outside of the quick stop who
will be involved in that we're not sure
yet
but these are things that we're talking
about dylan as far as a
few great artists how the usq universe
goes but let me
try to be an artist today with my paint
brush i always cut it in first
i don't have to be that close because
all this is going to be getting some
sort of crown molding base molding
so i really just want to get close to
the to the ceiling
all right so this is the rolling part so
i cut in this section here
we'll get that roller nice and nice and
wet
i usually put it on a little heavy first
just to get it on there yeah buddy
and then i kind of break it down
no lines no lines people
and now it's time for a lunch break yeah
now it's a lunch break chris has got
that right
all right guys i got the whole place
primed
i already started spraying the ceiling
black let's give you a little uh
a little bit of what we're doing here
with the spray gun
is the fun stuff a little messy though
[Music]
[Applause]
now we got the ceilings painted i moved
on to some of the trim
did that a nice eggshell black now i'm
working my way on the wall
got all that cut in doing a little bit
different variation of black on the
walls
kind of like a matte finish i'm gonna do
a little rolling for you
let's get it done baby
[Music]
today we're putting down the two-part
epoxy on the floor
uh we got the whole black box thing
going but we're gonna jazz
up a little bit a little bit of color
and the lifetime on this
epoxy is about three four hours you have
to add the catalyst
so we've got to work on this and today
it's kind of hot in here so
me and chris is sucking it up all right
so it looks like we got all the painting
done
for the smart castle floors walls
ceiling
so now it's on to putting the vip room
together
and all the other nonsense we'll see you
next time on the smart castle
[Music]
you